so I want to look today out as an
automata I was teaching a python module
but this has stopped and I teach a
module on on formal languages and
automata Theory which is theoretical
computer science this is like State
machines and things like that yeah the
final State machines yeah and regular
expressions
but today I think we just look at a
deterministic finite automata
but what I what yeah I I don't want to
give up this python thing altogether so
what I'm going to do is we're going to
implement
automata in Python
what is the language well it's a set of
words I suppose yeah the language is a
set of words that's very good well done
um what is a bird sets of characters no
it's a sequence of characters a sequence
of symbols actually a sequence of
symbols and actually this is the same as
a list a special list of symbols what's
the symbol uh alphabet yeah it's an
element of an of an alphabet and we we
usually use a big letter Sigma for for
the alphabet it's a final set of symbols
and often in in when we do Theory we
often have very small alphabets and one
symbol or two symbols but uh yeah that's
very good for examples so let's start
with an alphabet with Sigma you see if
you do if you do some math we need to
have some Greek letters that already
shows and then some math is coming and
let's just say we have a and b our
symbols and our language is a set of
words and it's all the words so let me
write L are all the words the A's come
before bees very simple language okay so
that's some example so let's say a a is
this okay yeah okay
[Music]
he's definitely before bees okay what
about ba well no no okay and what about
a b a
no that can't be and what about Epsilon
Epsilon is the empty word oh okay yeah
so that's okay though that's okay
okay so let's now build an automaton so
I'm talking today about d f
a
which is short for deterministic
finite
automaton
we will see in other types of our
terminals or for example the NFA is the
non-deterministic ones and we also see
regular Expressions which are related to
the same class of languages which are
called irregular languages but today
look at the simplest case of an
automaton a DFA and an what's a DFA so
we have a finite set of states
then we have transitions between states
which are labeled by the by the symbols
have some initial States we have one
initial State and then we have some
final States so I start with the state
0 and since this is a start state
okay throw an arrow that's when I start
it's like a very simple game right but
it's also a final
State because if I if you've seen if the
empty word is in the language
so let me do a double circle to say that
this is like a ghoul you know final step
now if we see an a we stay in this state
we have just seen Ace if we see a b
we go into a new state
one
which also is a final step we have some
seen some E's and one B so let me do
this turns into a final State I may have
seen more bees that's fine
I stay in the state
but
it could happen I see an A in which case
I'm unhappy so I go into State 2 which
is not a final state but it's my error
State and now I can have transition for
a I stay in my
unhappy State be I also stay in my
unhappy State now actually but look at
the examples we have
so how does this work so a a so yeah we
start here a candle with a finger once
we go to the non-deterministic one I
need several fingers and I think I'm
going to do with markers but I'm here I
see an a I stay here I mean I continue I
go back here a and now I'm finished I
let my a and I'm in a final state
automata says yes now a a b b what is
this a
a
now I have a b
another B
another B I mean the final state I'm
happy now ba what happens I start here
B I go there a I go there
and I finish and I'm not on a final
state
so I have lost
okay and now let's try this one
a
B
a bad state
and this one the empty word I start I'm
already done on an empty State okay
so the language of this automaton
is exactly what I wanted to describe the
words where the A's come into before B's
so here we are in in Python and The
Spider and I want to define a class of
DFAS and I do the usual boilerplate
so I Define an init method
which says okay what is the DFA we have
to have a set of States so I'm going to
use the set type of of python
there is a set of symbols which is
called Sigma I don't know how to do
Greek letters in in Python I think it's
possible but I haven't yet figured it
out there's another Greek letter the
Delta which I also spelled out which is
the transition function which gives
tells us if you understate and you have
a you have a symbol what is the next
state and I'm going to use a dictionary
for this transition function as a
dictionary
so we have an initial state which is the
one where the L goes in and we have a
set of final States and I also have a
simple print function so let me Define
our first automaton so this is the one
whereas all the A's are before the B's
and the set of state is 0 1 2
the set of symbols it's just a b and
here is our table if I find the
automotive
which implements exactly this automaton
so it says okay from zero if you've seen
a
you get to get a zero from zero if you
set a b you're going to State one and so
on from one if you've seen a
you go to two and so on the left just
encoded this little graph
as a dictionary in Python
now when I say 0 is the initial state
and 0 1 is a set of final States
okay
so now we have to do something versus
automaton so let's Implement a run
function
has a one function so I say here's a
word which I will just use a string to
represent it
so initially my state is the initial
state
and then I'm going to eat the word so
why the word is not empty
I'm using my my Delta to say okay I'm in
state q
I see the first symbol of the string and
I'm going to go into the new state and
assign it to Q again and then also
cut off the first symbol and when I
finish this I return a Boolean which
says there's a q is in set of final
symbols okay I did something wrong oh I
did my indentation level
okay okay now it works let's try our
examples if I find them again so here
we run
a
two
that's one d0 a a b b so this is two and
now let's run
ba
oh
d0 I mistyped
okay as false
oh let's do the
the empty
it's doing which is fine
okay ended up with one more let's let's
be complete
it will test sweet
thoughts so it seems to look
bed stairs is red and football is green
right it's a terrible example because
Hill's already the most likely there
could be many hundreds of words we could
I'm happy again
but now I have to say oh what happens if
I if I see a b here